to me up I think Brad I think right now
no I know it's tough and they they
select with no team record something
like that but not definitely think Brad
bill [ __ ] should be here
question I feel like Bradley Beal is
having an incredible year you know for
like he should have been one of those
guys who off the strength of the players
I thought you should have been here but
I mean yeah I feel like it's cuz of his
record but you know his performance is
incredible and I think he's an all-star
brother you mean cuz I watched him you
know I I saw him whole year you know his
heated oven you know he he literally
scored 30 points in the NBA and then he
walks her than that he does everything
you know everybody's own opinion you
know I think I'm more than deserving I
think there's a lot of guys that were
deserving to be all-star and you know
but that's individual stats as well I
think you have to understand that once
the team starts getting you know two
more wins and more recognition you know
then you get pushed forward a little bit
more as well I know for me personally
individual I know there wasn't 12 guys
that had a better season than me so far
but you know I also know that you know
we're not in the playoff race right now
we're we're tense so we have to do a
better job and get into there know me
know I know I'll make all starts in one
day
in the all-star game
I thought Devin Booker but he made his
way in
the last few years especially this year
I think he's having uh you know I wasn't
you know I was just on the great teams
you know we aren't even in the playoffs
and I made it and I feel like I paid my
blues I've been through that experience
that he's been through but I just feel
like he deserves to be here but he
deserve to be here oh you got guys like
DeMar DeRozan who's been all-star plenty
of times
it always deserves to be here but I
think you know for him to not have made
it once you know it was pretty cool to
be and I don't know I think there's a
lot of guys that have had unbelievable
seasons up to this point that could
easily be here for all-star weekend but
you know it's a tough decision